This guy I know, David Rudis, was talking to me on the phone last week. He wanted me to help out with this Jewish organization that he's part of. David is concerned about the fact that fewer and fewer Jews are joining Jewish organizations and identifying as Jews. He thinks those organizations need to make themselves more relevant to modern Jews.
我认识的一个人，大卫·鲁迪斯，上周给我打了个电话。他想让我帮他所在的犹太组织做些事情。大卫很担心现在加入犹太组织并认同自己是犹太人的年轻人越来越少。他认为这些组织需要做出改变，以适应现代犹太人的需求。
And I was telling him, that's fine for him, but that is just not my thing. Yes, I'm Jewish, but I don't believe in God. I married a non-Jew. I've been eating bread all this week during Passover. I have plenty of interesting Jews in my life and feel no need to meet any more. Why would I ever join a Jewish organization?
我告诉他，这对你来说可能很重要，但这并不是我的菜。是的，我是犹太人，但我不信上帝。我娶了一个非犹太人为妻。逾越节这一周我一直在吃面包。我的生活中已经有很多有趣的犹太朋友，我没必要再认识更多人了。我为什么要加入什么犹太组织呢？
This, of course, led to the brief obligatory discussion of the Holocaust, which is what we Jews always talk about at a point like this in a conversation like this. And David was very insistent that it doesn't matter if I think of myself as a Jew. I just am a Jew.
这自然引出了那个老生常谈的关于大屠杀的讨论，这是我们犹太人在这种谈话中总会谈到的。大卫非常坚持地认为，无论我是否认同自己是犹太人，这都不重要，因为我本质上就是一个犹太人。
I think, Ira, you don't even begin to realize how much this identity has affected your life. As an avid listener to your show, there is something profoundly Jewish in the contents of what you're producing, whether you know it or not.
我想，艾拉，你根本没有意识到这种身份认同对你的生活影响有多深。作为你节目的忠实听众，你所制作的内容中确实存在着某种深刻的犹太属性，无论你是否意识到这一点。
I'm so surprised to hear you say that you think of the show as a Jewish kind of cultural product, because I don't think of it that way at all.
听到你把这个节目看作一种犹太文化产品，我感到非常惊讶，因为我完全没有这样想过。
See, I actually think it is. If you're playing morality plays to get into the hearts and heads of people on a weekly basis, what is more Jewish than that, than telling and interpreting a story? It's in your DNA.
你看，我确实认为它是。如果你每周都在用道德剧来触动人们的心灵和思想，还有什么比讲故事和解读故事更具犹太特色呢？这就在你的基因里。
I suggested to him that telling stories is kind of something that every culture does, not just the Jews. David says sure, but so what?
我向他建议，讲故事是每种文化都会做的事情，不仅仅是犹太人。大卫说当然，但那又怎样？
Literally what you're doing really is profoundly Jewish.
从字面上看，你所做的确实是深刻的犹太文化。
It was a weird conversation. David thinks that in our big, multicultural world, of course it is just old-fashioned for people to identify strictly with their own ethnic tribe. He told me that he remembered when he first moved to Chicago decades ago, it was standard back then for people to just meet you and ask what are you? Meaning, what neighborhood are you from? What parish? What religion?
那是一场奇怪的对话。大卫认为，在我们这个多元文化的广阔世界里，人们严格认同自己的种族部落当然是过时的。他告诉我，他记得几十年前刚搬到芝加哥时，人们见面时问“你是哪儿人？”是很常见的，意思是你来自哪个社区？哪个教区？信奉什么宗教？
It seemed really weird to him at the time. But at that same time as he was saying this he says-- no contradiction here-- he just likes having his own tribe and would like me to come join the herd.
当时他觉得这真的很奇怪。但与此同时，他话锋一转说——这并不矛盾——他就是喜欢有自己的部落，也希望我能加入这个群体。
There's a scientist at UCLA named Jared Diamond, who came out recently with this book called The World Until Yesterday that's about how humans lived on this planet until about 10,000 years ago. When everybody lived, literally, in a tribe of a few hundred people, or a small band of a few dozen people. And Jared Diamond writes this thing about life then, about what it means to actually live in a tribe, that I had never heard before that really just stuck with me.
加州大学洛杉矶分校有一位科学家叫贾里德·戴蒙德，他最近出了一本书叫《昨日世界》，讲述了人类在1万年前的生活方式。那时每个人都确实生活在只有几百人甚至几十人的小型部落里。贾里德·戴蒙德写了一些关于当时生活的内容，关于真正生活在一个部落中意味着什么，我以前从未听说过，这些内容真的让我深有感触。
He says that in these societies, because they were so small, you knew everybody. You never encountered strangers. You never ran into them.
他说，在这些社会中，因为规模非常小，每个人你都认识。你从不会遇到陌生人。你永远不会碰到他们。
The idea that you could just wander around and meet someone is utterly impossible in New Guinea. If you ran across a strange person on your land, that could only mean that they were there for some bad reason. They were there to scout out your land for a raid, or to steal a woman, or to steal a pig.
在新几内亚，那种你可以随意走动并遇见陌生人的想法是完全不可能的。如果你在自己的土地上偶然发现一个陌生人，那只能说明他来者不善。他们是为了侦察你的土地以便突袭，或者为了偷一个女人，或者偷一头猪。
And so if you ran into a strange person in the forest and you couldn't run away from him, you came around a corner and there he was, then the two of you would sit down. And you'd have a long conversation in which each of you names all your relatives, trying to find some relative in common which gives you a reason not to kill each other. And if after two hours you haven't found any relative in common, then one of you starts running or you try to kill the other person.
所以，如果你在森林里遇到一个陌生人而又无法逃跑，当你在拐角处撞见他时，你们俩就会坐下来。然后你们会进行长时间的交谈，每个人都要列举出所有的亲属，试图找到某个共同的亲戚，这能给你们一个不杀死对方的理由。如果两个小时后还没找到共同亲戚，那么你们其中一人就会开始逃跑，或者试图杀死对方。
Diamond talked to me on the phone from Jakarta. He had just gotten there. Back to electricity and showers after three weeks off the grid in Papua, New Guinea.
戴蒙德在雅加达给我打了电话。他刚到那里。在巴布亚新几内亚与世隔绝了三周后，终于又回到了有电和淋浴的文明世界。
I wanted to speak with him, because I wondered what he thought this story meant. Was he saying, OK, this is who we are? This is just built into us to be suspicious and fearful of outsiders? To want to stick to our own tribe?
我想和他谈谈，因为我很好奇他是怎么理解这个故事的。他是在说，好吧，这就是我们的本性吗？怀疑和恐惧外人、想要坚持属于自己的部落，这难道是与生俱来的吗？
It's going too far to do that. People can be more or less suspicious of strangers, and it depends upon the circumstance.
那样说就太过了。人们对陌生人的怀疑程度各不相同，这取决于具体情况。
And so he says, for instance, the circumstances when humans lived in small traditional societies, there was good reason to fear strangers. As soon as human societies grew bigger, into groups of thousands of people, you'd run into strangers all the time. It was normal. You wouldn't have these same reasons to fear strangers, and so we stopped in lots of places.
因此他说，例如，当人类生活在小型传统社会时，恐惧陌生人是有充分理由的。随着人类社会变大，发展成拥有成千上万人的群体时，你会经常遇到陌生人。这很正常。你不会再有同样的理由去恐惧陌生人，所以我们在很多地方不再那样做了。
Though apropos of my conversation with David Rudis, Jared Diamond said that one of the things that does seem to have been true of traditional small societies 10,000 years ago that is still true today is an obsession with who's in and who's out, and seeing that people stick with the rules.
虽然关于我和大卫·鲁迪斯的谈话，贾里德·戴蒙德说，1万年前传统小型社会中似乎确实存在的一件事，直到今天依然真实，那就是对“谁是圈内人，谁是圈外人”的执着，以及确保人们遵守规则。
It's whenever there's a group, you have the problem of figuring out who really is a member of your group. And who is just pretending to be a member of the group for advantages. That may be part of the reason why humans have these very complicated cultures, including languages and body mutilation.
每当有一个群体存在时，你就会遇到弄清楚谁才是真正的成员的问题。而谁只是为了利益而假装是成员。这可能就是为什么人类拥有如此复杂的文化，包括语言和身体改造的部分原因。
If I come into a group and I say, I'm really a long-lost member of your group but I can't speak your language and I haven't tattooed myself. Then it'll immediately be obvious that I'm not a member of your group. So all groups have what are called "expensive" ways of identifying themselves honestly so that you can't just fake it.
如果我进入一个群体并说，我确实是你们失散多年的成员，但我不会说你们的语言，也没有纹身，那立刻就会很明显我不是你们群体的一员。所以所有群体都有所谓的“昂贵”方式来诚实地证明自己的身份，这样你就无法伪装。
Right. And the reason why it's so universal, is it just because if somebody can sneak in and be part of your group then they're getting access to stuff that's really yours?
没错。而这种现象如此普遍的原因，难道仅仅是因为如果有人可以混进来成为你们群体的一部分，那么他们就能获得原本属于你们的东西吗？
That's right. The term is "freeloader."
没错。这个词叫“搭便车者”。
[INAUDIBLE] he says that that is the actual scientific term. That's the one that anthropologists use-- "freeloader."
他说这就是科学术语。那是人类学家使用的术语——“搭便车者”。
Well today on our radio show, we hear very different kinds of groups struggle with this question, who's in and who's out. It's the question which, of course, over history has led to purges, witch hunts, factionalism, the assassination of Trotsky, the Spanish Inquisition. Nobody expects the Spanish Inquisition, right? Well, we probably should. It happens all the time.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们听到了不同类型的群体在与这个问题作斗争：谁是圈内人，谁是圈外人。当然，这个问题在历史上导致了清洗、猎巫、派系斗争、托洛茨基遇刺、西班牙宗教裁判所。没人会预料到西班牙宗教裁判所，对吧？好吧，我们可能应该预料到。这事儿一直在发生。
Today on our program we have three stories of three groups, including one whose defining characteristic is that they talk very evenly and softly. From WBEZ, Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有三个关于三个群体的故事，包括一个其定义特征是说话非常平稳轻柔的群体。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这里是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, I Know I Am, But What Are You?
第一幕：我知道我是，但你是谁？
This story is about a group arguing over that most basic thing that any group can fight over-- who should be a member. The group is an Indian tribe in California, the Chukchansi, in the middle of the state. Currently about 900 members. One of many small tribes in California, and the dispute has gotten pretty bitter. David Ferry explains just how far they've gone.
这个故事是关于一个群体为了任何群体都会争吵的最基本问题而争执——谁应该成为成员。这个群体是加利福尼亚州中部的一个印第安部落，查克钱西人。目前约有900名成员。这是加州众多小部落之一，争议已经变得相当激烈。大卫·费里解释了他们闹到了什么地步。
Here's how bad things have gotten with the Chukchansi. About a year ago they had an election for their tribal government-- it's called the tribal council. Four people won majorities, but the old counsel refused to step down. They disqualified the winners and changed the locks on the tribe's equivalent of City Hall, which is actually a trailer like you'd see on a construction site, but a little bigger.
这是查克钱西人目前的糟糕处境。大约一年前他们进行了部落政府选举——被称为部落委员会。四个人获得了多数票，但旧委员会拒绝下台。他们取消了获胜者的资格，并更换了部落相当于市政厅的锁，那其实就是一个你在建筑工地上能看到的拖车，只是稍微大一点。
So two dozen tribal members who wanted the candidates they voted in to actually take office decided to go to City Hall, the trailer, early one morning and occupy the building.
于是，两打想要让他们投票选出的候选人真正上任的部落成员决定，在一个清晨去占领市政厅，也就是那个拖车。
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
开始了。开始了。开始了。开始了。开始了。
This is from video taken by one of the occupiers of the building. It was meant to be a peaceful takeover, although they did break a window to get inside. They made coffee, ordered pizza and walked around the trailer with homemade signs. But loyalists of the incumbents, the counsel  that refused to step down, started showing up. They were angry.
这是其中一名占领者拍摄的视频。本意是一场和平接管，尽管他们确实打碎了一扇窗户才进去。他们煮了咖啡，点了披萨，拿着自制的标语在拖车里走来走去。但现任者的忠实拥护者，即那个拒绝下台的委员会，开始出现了。他们很愤怒。
Easy. Hey, calm down. Calm down.
冷静点。嘿，冷静点。冷静点。
Dude, what about that [INAUDIBLE]?
老兄，那件事怎么办？
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
（交谈声）
Get back in there.
退回去。
Calm down, you guys. [BLEEP]
你们冷静点。（脏话）
One of the winning candidates who wasn't allowed to take her seat is Dixie Jackson. She was inside the trailer for the occupation. She thought she heard a gunshot at one point.
其中一位获胜但未被允许就职的候选人是迪克西·杰克逊。她在占领期间待在拖车里。她当时以为听到了一声枪响。
I said hit it, and I went down and hit the floor. Well then, I couldn't get up because, of course, I got a bad hip and bad knees.
我说趴下，于是我倒下趴在地板上。嗯，然后我起不来了，因为当然，我的髋关节和膝盖都不好。
Dixie's in her 70s. Here's Morris Read, another winner, also in his 70s.
迪克西已经70多岁了。这是莫里斯·里德，另一位获胜者，也70多岁了。
Once they broke the windows, they started spraying in that pepper spray. And we started to have a hard time breathing. And then all of a sudden they're throwing in burning logs. I think there was two of them that they threw through the window. And our people get wet rags and papers where we could put over our mouths so we could breathe.
一旦他们打破窗户，就开始喷辣椒喷雾。我们开始呼吸困难。突然间，他们扔进来了燃烧的木头。我想他们从窗户扔进来了两根。我们的人用湿抹布和纸捂住嘴，这样才能呼吸。
We're not walking out! You were voted out by 150! Walk away! You walk away!
我们不会出去的！你们是以150票的差距被选下去的！走开！你们走开！
By nighttime, the occupation had turned into a siege. A crowd of 50 people outside cut off the power to the building, and then the water. They shot more pepper spray down into the ventilation system. Dixie and Morris and the other elders crowded into a tiny bathroom in the middle of the trailer for safety.
到了晚上，占领演变成了一场围困。外面50人的群众切断了建筑的电力，然后是水源。他们向通风系统喷射了更多的辣椒喷雾。迪克西、莫里斯和其他长者为了安全，挤进了拖车中间的一个小洗手间里。
Someone called the cops and they showed up-- sheriffs from Fresno and Madera County, and the California Highway Patrol. But they couldn't intervene, because this was an internal tribal matter. By morning, 40 people were fist fighting in the parking lot outside the trailer. Local TV crews captured the tail end of it.
有人叫了警察，他们赶到了——来自弗雷斯诺和马德拉县的警长，以及加州公路巡警。但他们无法干预，因为这是部落内部事务。到早上，40个人在拖车外的停车场斗殴。当地电视摄制组拍下了结尾。
In the midst of the madness, one teenager was stabbed and two people were injured.
在混乱中，一名十几岁的少年被刺伤，两人受伤。
All your people are going to [BLEEP] prison for this, too.
你们所有人都将因为这件事去坐牢的。
Two people were taken into custody. As for what caused the fighting--
两人被拘留。至于引发斗殴的原因——
This failed occupation, the election fiasco, it's all about one thing-- something called "disenrollment." That's the word Indians use for kicking someone out of the tribe. They get disenrolled.
这次失败的占领，选举闹剧，全都归结为一件事——被称为“取消会员资格”。这是印第安人用来踢人出部落的词。他们被取消了资格。
For years now, the Chukchansi tribe has been disenrolling its own members-- dozens, sometimes hundreds of people at a time. The tribal members who occupy the trailer, the winners of the election, they wanted to stop the disenrollments-- the people outside didn't. Lots of tribes in California are disenrolling people, but the Chukchansi are sort of a poster tribe for it. Best estimates have the tribe shrinking from about 1,800 people, down to about 900.
多年来，查克钱西部落一直在取消其成员的资格——有时是几十人，有时是数百人。占领拖车的部落成员，即选举的获胜者，他们想要停止取消资格——而外面的人则不想。加州的许多部落都在取消成员资格，但查克钱西人算是其中的典型代表。据估计，该部落已从约1800人缩减至约900人。
So the tribe has cut itself in half, and almost all this has happened since they opened a casino. A big, shiny Casino with a spa, and a hotel, and a high roller club, 10 years ago in 2003.
所以部落将自己的人数砍去了一半，而这一切几乎都发生在他们10年前，即2003年开设赌场之后。这是一个拥有水疗中心、酒店和豪客俱乐部的又大又亮眼的赌场。
At the foot of beautiful Yosemite Valley, there's a sound.
在美丽的优胜美地山谷脚下，有一种声音。
Cha-ching!
咔嚓！（老虎机中奖声）
This is one of their ads.
这是他们的广告之一。
Can you hear it? The sound of winning.
你能听到吗？获胜的声音。
Let me hear that cha-ching!
让我听到那个声音！
Oh yeah, Chukchansi Gold Resort and Casino.
哦，是的，查克钱西黄金度假村和赌场。
The sweet sound of cha-ching!
甜蜜的获胜声！
The math is simple. If they have fewer people in the tribe, each person gets more of the sweet sound of cha-ching-- more profit from the casino. Right now each Chukchansi only gets a few hundred dollars a month in casino profits. A tribal member named Nicki Livingston told me that when her friend Nancy was kicked out a few months ago, she could see it in her payout check.
数学很简单。如果部落里的人越少，每个人得到的钱就越多——从赌场获得的利润也就越多。目前每个查克钱西人每月只能获得几百美元的赌场利润。一位名叫尼基·利文斯顿的部落成员告诉我，当她的朋友南希几个月前被踢出去时，她在支付支票中看到了这一点。
We got a raise on our per capita check after she got disenrolled.
她被取消资格后，我们的人均支票涨了。
You got more money per month after your close friend was disenrolled from the tribe?
在你最好的朋友被取消部落资格后，你每个月得到的钱更多了？
Yeah. Me and my sisters, my two older sisters and myself, we were together when we heard that news. And we saw it [INAUDIBLE] saw it on our bank statements, and all three of us cried. It's done off the skin of someone's back.
是的。我和我的姐妹们，我的两个姐姐和我自己，我们在听到那个消息时在一起。我们在银行对账单上看到了这一点，我们三个都哭了。这是剥削别人的代价。
She says the checks were around $280 per month before Nancy and several dozen other people were kicked out. She says it jumped about $380 a month after. There's another tribe just down the road from the Chukchansi, and its paid tens of thousands of dollars a month to each member. And that's because their tribe only has around 75 people.
她说在南希和几十个人被踢出去之前，支票大约是每月280美元。她说在那之后涨到了大约每月380美元。查克钱西部落下方的路上还有另一个部落，每个成员每月可以获得数万美元。那是因为他们的部落只有大约75个人。
Chukchansi officials usually deny that disenrollment has anything to do with casino money. They say all they're doing is correcting the membership rolls. Getting rid of the people who don't belong in the tribe. But Reggie Lewis, the tribal chairman who refused to step down when he was voted out of office, said to me, sure money has something to do with disenrollments, but why shouldn't it?
查克钱西的官员通常否认取消资格与赌场金钱有关。他们说他们所做的只是纠正成员名册。清除那些不属于部落的人。但是拒绝在被选下台时下台的部落主席雷吉·刘易斯对我表示，钱确实与取消资格有关，但为什么不呢？
We don't have that much to share. We've got tribal members who are living in gutted out trailers with no sanitary facilities, without power. And then we have people who are trying to take advantage of being a tribal member when they're not entitled to be in.
我们没有那么多东西可以分享。我们有部落成员住在没有卫生设施、没有电的破烂拖车里。然后有些人试图利用部落成员的身份，尽管他们没有资格加入。
[MUFFLED SOUNDS]
（声音模糊）
This is the sound of my producer putting the microphone away as we're talking to a Chukchansi woman who'd agreed to be interviewed, but was so worried about repercussions that she kept going off the record or going silent. By the time I got to her, I was used to this. So many Chukchansi refused to talk, or agreed but then backed out saying that they were too scared. I asked this woman, who didn't want her name used, what people are scared of.
这是我的制片人在我们采访一位查克钱西妇女时收起麦克风的声音，她同意接受采访，但因为太担心后果，不断要求不录音或保持沉默。当我找到她时，我已经习惯了。太多的查克钱西人拒绝交谈，或者同意后又反悔，说他们太害怕了。我问这位不想透露姓名的妇女，人们在怕什么。
In my opinion, most of them are afraid because they either have members, loved ones or themselves that are employed.
在我看来，他们大多数人很害怕，因为他们的家人、爱人，或者是他们自己被雇佣了。
How many people do you think you know who've been fired from the casino?
你认为你认识的人中有多少人被赌场解雇了？
What's happening in the silence after my question is she's pointing at the microphone and shaking her head no. This woman had already been disenrolled, and she still didn't want to talk. She has family members who work at the casino. And like everyone else we met like that, she took it as a given, rightly or wrongly, that they might be fired if she spoke out.
我在问题后的沉默中发生的事情是，她指着麦克风并摇头表示否认。这位妇女已经被取消了资格，但她仍然不想说话。她有家庭成员在赌场工作。就像我们遇到的其他人一样，无论正确与否，她都认为如果她敢说话，他们可能会被解雇。
The tribal council appoints the people who oversee the casino. There aren't a lot of jobs in this part of California. And the tribal council's very powerful-- in the community, and in the casino.
部落委员会任命监管赌场的人。加州这一带的工作岗位不多。部落委员会非常强大——在社区和赌场里都是。
Disenrollment could mean serious financial hardship. When you're part of the tribe, you get a bunch of services. So on top of losing the monthly casino payout, people who are disenrolled also lose subsidies for child care and housing. Older members lose more-- a $300 monthly food stipend and extra cash to cover utilities. So no surprise there's now this culture of paranoia in the tribe. The anti-disenrollment folks are sure that some people who seem to be on their side are really spies for the other side.
取消资格可能意味着严重的经济困难。当你成为部落的一部分时，你可以获得一堆服务。因此，除了失去每月的赌场分红外，被取消资格的人还会失去儿童保育和住房补助。年长的成员损失更多——每月300美元的食物津贴和额外的公用事业补助。所以部落中存在这种偏执文化并不奇怪。反取消资格的一派确信，一些看似站在他们这边的人其实是另一方的间谍。
I was talking to Morris Reed and Dixie Jackson, the ones who were elected to the tribal council but never seated. They're the ones who hid in the trailer choking on pepper spray. And Dixie said that at one point they tried to get tribal members to sign a petition supporting them, calling for an end to disenrollment. She said it went nowhere.
我和莫里斯·里德以及迪克西·杰克逊交谈，他们是入选部落委员会但从未就职的人。他们就是躲在拖车里被辣椒喷雾呛到的人。迪克西说，他们一度试图让部落成员签署请愿书支持他们，呼吁结束取消资格。她说这毫无进展。
Even our own family says that they don't want to sign. Because then their names will be on the list that we support you, and therefore we will be subject to retaliation.
就连我们自己的家人也说他们不想签名。因为那样他们的名字就会出现在支持我们的名单上，从而会遭到报复。
Dixie said one of her daughters had been fired from the casino two weeks earlier. She suspected it was retaliation against her family for occupying the trailer and opposing the tribal council. A casino spokesman told me the firing was not political.
迪克西说她的一个女儿两周前在赌场被解雇了。她怀疑这是针对她们家占领拖车并反对部落委员会的报复。赌场发言人告诉我解雇并非出于政治原因。
As Dixie was telling me about all this, the phone rang. We were sitting around Morris's kitchen table. Morris answered it, and it was actually for Dixie.
当迪克西告诉我这些时，电话响了。我们坐在莫里斯的餐桌旁。莫里斯接了电话，其实是找迪克西的。
Yes, she is. Do you want to talk to her? Somebody wants to talk to you.
是的，她在。你想和她说话吗？有人想和你说话。
Yes? Yes.
喂？是的。
Dixie didn't talk long. It was about another daughter who still worked at the casino.
迪克西没说多久。那是关于另一个还在赌场工作的女儿。
They walked the other one out today.
他们今天把另一个也带走了。
Wait.
等等。
Just now.
就在刚才。
Wait.
等等。
Wait, what?
等等，什么？
They walked my daughter, the other daughter that was director of floor games.
他们把我的女儿带走了，就是那个做地板游戏主管的女儿。
OK, yes.
好的，是的。
They walked her out just now.
他们刚刚把她带走了。
Your daughter was just fired?
你女儿刚被解雇了？
Uh huh.
嗯。
The casino said this firing was also unrelated to the family's politics.
赌场表示这次解雇也与该家庭的政治立场无关。
Bryan Galt saw how the disenrollments got started, and he's one of the few who saw it from the inside. He worked in the Chukchansi Enrollment Office, the office that decides who's a member and who's not. Back in 2003, when the casino first opened, the enrollment office was really just a room, he says, with six file cabinets and a computer. But it was where the tribe stored all of its documents on everybody's ancestry. Before the casino was built, you just needed a birth certificate and some proof that you're a lineal descendant of a Chukchansi.
布莱恩·高特目睹了取消资格是如何开始的，他是少数从内部看到这一点的人之一。他在查克钱西登记办公室工作，该办公室负责决定谁是成员谁不是。2003年赌场刚开业时，登记办公室其实只是一个房间，他说，放着六个文件柜和一台电脑。但那是部落存储所有人祖先文件的地方。在赌场建成之前，你只需要出生证明和一些证明你是查克钱西直系后代的证据。
I don't think you can imagine a more messed up filing system. Because it had been years of just people just shoving stuff in the files.
我想你无法想象一个比这更混乱的文件系统。因为多年来人们只是把东西随便塞进文件里。
You were there though. Was the enrollment committee about letting people in, or was it about kicking people out?
你当时在那里。登记委员会是为了让人们进来，还是为了把人踢出去？
Well initially it was to help straighten out the records because they in such disarray. And then the casino opened, and then it started to become a head hunting expedition. Find out how people can be disenrolled.
起初是为了帮助整理记录，因为它们太混乱了。然后赌场开了，然后它开始变成一场猎头远征。找出人们如何能被取消资格。
Bryan says that mandate came from the top, the tribal council, but he didn't agree with it.
布莱恩说那个指令来自高层，即部落委员会，但他不同意。
My committee, we refused to take action against anyone who was already enrolled because we didn't think it was fair. You're going to what-- tell 80-year-old ladies that they're going to have to go to the National Archive and find information that no one had ever told them they needed for the last 15 years? They're enrolled-- just leave it at that.
我的委员会，我们拒绝针对任何已经登记在册的人采取行动，因为我们认为这不公平。你们要干什么——告诉80岁的老太太，她们必须去国家档案馆查找过去15年来没人告诉过她们需要的信息？她们已经登记了——就那样吧。
So we argued for the next two years about this. Have you ever seen a Jerry Springer episode? You'd go to monthly meetings, and that's how it was.
所以我们在接下来的两年里一直为此争论。你看过杰瑞·斯普林格的节目吗？你会去参加月度会议，情况就是那样。
There was no Dances With Wolves type mentality. I hate that movie for that reason. They show the wise old tribal chief, you know, that's all I have to say, and everyone's polite to each other through the whole meeting. And I'm like, I don't know what meeting those guys are at, but I've never been to one of those.
没有那种《与狼共舞》的精神。我讨厌那部电影就是这个原因。他们展示了睿智的老部落首领，你知道，这就是我要说的，每个人在整个会议期间都互相客气。我就想，我不知道这些人是在哪个会议上，但我从来没参加过那种会议。
This is a small tribe, remember. Everyone knows everybody else. And everyone thinks they know who's pushing to disenroll people.
记住，这是一个小部落。每个人都认识其他人。每个人都认为他们知道是谁在推动取消人们的资格。
There's a family called the Wyatts, and there's another called the Ramirezes. The Ramirezes actually filed a lawsuit last year, arguing that they are the only legitimate members of the tribe-- just their family. The case was thrown out. I reached out to members of both families, but no one agreed to speak on tape.
有一个叫怀亚特的家庭，还有一个叫拉米雷斯的家庭。拉米雷斯一家去年确实提起诉讼，认为他们是部落唯一合法的成员——只有他们的家族。该案被驳回了。我联系了两个家族的成员，但没人同意录音采访。
One person who's supported disenrollment for years is Reggie Lewis. He's the tribal leader you heard from earlier who refused to step down after the election. He says the disenrollments are necessary because of the weird history of the tribe. The Federal government disbanded them in 1958, along with lots of other California tribes. And when they started up again in the 1980s, he says they were in a rush. That they didn't really know what they were doing.
多年来一直支持取消资格的一个人是雷吉·刘易斯。他是你之前听到的那位在选举后拒绝下台的部落领导人。他说，由于部落奇怪的历史，取消资格是有必要的。联邦政府在1958年解散了他们，以及加州的其他许多部落。当他们在80年代重新开始时，他说他们很匆忙。他们并不真正知道自己在做什么。
For a long time, our tribe was looked that as kind of a joke as far as membership. Because they were saying oh yeah, the Chukchansi tribe, that's a country club. You can go up and join. They just knew that they could get in.
很长一段时间里，我们的部落在会员资格方面被视为一个笑话。因为他们说哦是的，查克钱西部落，那是一个乡村俱乐部。你可以上去加入。他们只是知道他们能进来。
And so he says they had to make a lot of hard choices. He told me he even voted to disenroll his own cousins-- he had to.
所以他说他们不得不做出许多艰难的选择。他告诉我，他甚至投票取消了他自己表亲的资格——他不得不这样做。
They are my cousins, but they didn't have any Chukchansi in them. For years they thought that they were Chukchansi. We thought they were Chukchansi. When the research was done, we find out that no, they were not even Indians. They were white people.
他们是我的表亲，但他们身上没有任何查克钱西血统。多年来他们以为他们是查克钱西人。我们以为他们是查克钱西人。研究完成后，我们发现不，他们甚至不是印第安人。他们是白人。
The fact is, even tribes that aren't disenrolling people have a hard time figuring out how to decide who's in the tribe. What's important-- blood line? DNA? Language? Land ownership?
事实是，即使是没有取消成员资格的部落，也很难弄清楚如何决定谁是部落成员。什么是重要的——血缘？DNA？语言？土地所有权？
In California, tribes were hunted down and forced to disband. To abandon their land and their language. There was lots of intermarriage. Records were lost. It's a mess.
在加利福尼亚，部落被追捕并被迫解散。放弃他们的土地和语言。有很多跨种族通婚。记录丢失了。这是一团糟。
So the Chukchansi settled on a set of arcane rules based on land ownership and ancestry to determine who could stay in their tribe. If your family had Chukchansi ancestry but no one got a land grant from the Federal government long ago, you were given a one-year deadline to get in your paperwork. If you didn't make the deadline or the extension, you were disenrolled. If you're one of the luckier families that was deeded land, for you there's no deadline. But your ancestry gets combed over and scrutinized for any hint of non-Chukchansiness.
所以查克钱西人决定了一套基于土地所有权和血统的晦涩规则来确定谁可以留在他们的部落。如果你的家族有查克钱西血统，但没有人从联邦政府获得土地补助，你就会获得一年的截止日期来提交文书。如果你没有在截止日期或延期之前完成，你就会被取消资格。如果你是比较幸运的、有土地契约的家庭之一，对你来说没有截止日期。但你的血统会受到仔细审查，以寻找任何非查克钱西特征的迹象。
This is the letter I got right here.
这封信就是我收到的。
This is Irene Cordero. She got a letter recently from the tribe telling her she was disenrolled because her grandfather Jack Roan had in some official documents said he was Chukchansi and in some others said he was Pohonichi. Irene says what's the problem? He was both. But the tribe kicked her out along with about 70 members of her family, including her mother Ruby.
这是艾琳·科德罗。她最近收到了部落的一封信，告诉她她被取消了资格，因为她的祖父杰克·罗恩在一些官方文件中说他是查克钱西人，而在另一些文件中说他是波霍尼奇人。艾琳说有什么问题吗？他两者都是。但部落把她和她家族大约70名成员一起踢了出去，包括她的母亲鲁比。
She's the oldest Chukchansi there is now. Last one passed away last week, I think.
她是现在最老的查克钱西人了。我想上周最后一个去世了。
We couldn't confirm that Irene's mother was the oldest Chukchansi. We also couldn't find a Chukchansi that was older.
我们无法确认艾琳的母亲是否是最老的查克钱西人。我们也没能找到比她年龄更大的查克钱西人。
She'll be 90 in January.
她在1月份就90岁了。
And she's a native speaker of the language?
她是这种语言的母语使用者？
Uh huh.
嗯。
How many native speakers are there around?
还有多少母语使用者？
About two.
大约两个。
There are actually more like six.
其实大约有六个。
Disenrollment letters all end with a line saying the tribal council's decisions are final and not appeal-able to any state or federal court. There's nowhere to go to say but wait, this woman speaks Chukchansi. Doesn't that count somehow? Irene can't take this to the US courts or the Bureau of Indian Affairs and expect any help, because each tribe operates like it's own separate country. And for the Chukchansi, the tribal council's the final authority.
取消资格的信件末尾都有一行字，说部落委员会的决定是最终决定，不能向任何州或联邦法院上诉。没有地方可以说，等等，这位妇女会说查克钱西语。这难道不算数吗？艾琳不能把这件事告到美国法院或印第安事务局并期待任何帮助，因为每个部落的运作就像它自己的独立国家一样。而对于查克钱西人来说，部落委员会是最终权威。
A few months after the tribe disenrolled Irene's mother Ruby, one of the last remaining native speakers, they gave a million dollars to a local university for the study and revitalization of the Chukchansi language.
在部落取消艾琳的母亲鲁比（最后几位母语使用者之一）资格后的几个月，他们给当地一所大学捐赠了一百万美元，用于研究和复兴查克钱西语。
Honorable tribal council, the enrollment committee's prepared to present evidence as to why the respondents are not eligible for membership.
尊敬的部落委员会，登记委员会准备提交证据，说明为什么响应者没有资格获得会员资格。
This is a recording of a disenrollment hearing. It's actually Bryan Galt's disenrollment hearing. He's the guy who worked in the enrollment office and fought against the new mandate to kick people out. He ended up defending his own membership in the tribe in 2006, three years after the casino opened.
这是一份取消资格听证会的录音。这实际上是布莱恩·高特的取消资格听证会。他就是那个在登记办公室工作并反对踢人出局的新授权的人。他在2006年，即赌场开业三年后，最终为自己的部落成员身份进行了辩护。
These hearings are closed to the public, and to the rest of the tribe, too. Bryan recorded this secretly and then posted it online. What's most striking is how much time is devoted to asserting and reasserting that this whole process is legal, and it's being done according to the tribe's constitution and its ordinances. Everyone's just following the rules.
这些听证会对公众不开放，对部落的其他成员也不开放。布莱恩偷偷录下了这个，然后发布到了网上。最令人震惊的是，他们花费了大量时间来断言并重申整个过程是合法的，并且是根据部落的宪法和条例进行的。每个人只是在遵循规则。
But anyone who is sitting there about to be disenrolled knows that the tribe, as its own sovereign nation of about 900 people, can change those rules at any time. So that there wouldn't be hearings to disenroll someone like Bryan, who in fact has Chukchansi ancestry. Which the tribe acknowledges during the hearing to kick him out.
但任何坐在那里即将被取消资格的人都知道，作为一个由大约900人组成的自治国家，部落可以在任何时候改变这些规则。这样就不会有听证会来取消像布莱恩这样的人的资格，他实际上拥有查克钱西血统。部落在踢他出局的听证会上承认了这一点。
For his great great grandmother Mary Galt. From the committee I'd like to indicate that Mary Galt is of Chukchansi Indian blood, four quarters.
对于他的曾曾祖母玛丽·高特。委员会想指出玛丽·高特是查克钱西印第安血统，纯血。
So not only does he have a full-blooded Chukchansi relative, Bryan's family actually got land from the Federal government more than a century ago. But the problem is, the council decides it's the wrong kind of land. So in the end, the thing that does him in is the he just didn't get his paperwork in by the deadline.
所以他不仅有一位纯血统的查克钱西亲戚，布莱恩的家族实际上在一个多世纪前就从联邦政府获得了土地。但问题是，委员会决定这是错误的土地类型。所以最后，让他完蛋的事情是他没能在截止日期前提交文书。
October 22, 1988, through April 3, 1990. Therefore, the enrollment committee requests that James Bryan Galt is not eligible for membership pursuant to the tribe's constitution, and therefore requests that he be disenrolled.
1988年10月22日至1990年4月3日。因此，登记委员会根据部落宪法要求，詹姆斯·布莱恩·高特没有资格获得会员资格，因此要求取消他的资格。
The same day Bryan found out he'd been disenrolled, he lost his job as a beverage manager and web director for the casino. The casino spokesman told me the firing had nothing to do with his disenrollment.
布莱恩发现自己被取消资格的同一天，他失去了赌场饮料经理和网页总监的工作。赌场发言人告诉我解雇与他的取消资格无关。
Tribes across the country are watching these mass disenrollments by the Chukchansi and others, and they're just flabbergasted. Here's David Wilkins. He's a Lumbee Indian, and a professor of American Indian studies at the University of Minnesota.
全国各地的部落都在注视着查克钱西人和其他人的大规模取消资格，他们完全惊呆了。这是大卫·威尔金斯。他是伦比印第安人，明尼苏达大学美国印第安研究教授。
I get shocked every time I read any Country Today and see that another tribe, usually it's out of California, that has decided that they're going to disenroll another 22 families.
我每次阅读《今日国家》看到另一个部落，通常是在加利福尼亚州，决定再取消22个家庭的资格时，我都感到震惊。
Wilkins is one of the few people who studies disenrollment.
威尔金斯是少数研究取消资格的人之一。
Disenrollment is occurring now in some 17 states. It's occurring in at least 30 tribes in California. I can't find a definitive number on how many native individuals have formally been disenrolled.
取消资格现在发生在17个州。它发生在加利福尼亚州的至少30个部落中。我无法找到有多少本土个人被正式取消资格的明确数字。
I see figures ranging 4,000 to 6,000. But it's difficult to find accurate data because, like I say, tribal governments are not going to be forthcoming with this information. The Bureau of Indian Affairs refuses to share this information because they say that it's a tribal internal matter. And so as a scholar, as a researcher, I'm frustrated and embittered because I can't find the accurate data to get the word out about what we're doing to ourselves.
我看到的数字范围在4000到6000之间。但很难找到准确的数据，因为正如我所说，部落政府不会向公众提供这些信息。印第安事务局拒绝分享这些信息，因为他们说这是部落内部事务。所以作为一名学者和研究人员，我感到沮丧和苦涩，因为我找不到准确的数据来传播我们对自己做了什么。
Wilkins told me other tribes are watching the Chukchansi and others disenroll their members with no consequences and so they're trying it, too. And he said something that I'd heard from a lot of Indians. We were almost wiped out by other people. And why are we now whittling ourselves away through disenrollments?
威尔金斯告诉我，其他部落正在观察查克钱西人和其他人毫无后果地取消其成员的资格，所以他们也在尝试。他说了一句我从许多印第安人那里听到的话。我们差点被别人消灭。为什么我们现在通过取消资格来削弱自己？
And this is what I find most frustrating when I have to say that we really are involved in depopulating ourselves. And at this point we can't blame the Federal government, we can't blame the state that we're in. We have to look at ourselves in the mirror and try and explain this to ourselves.
当我不得不说我们确实正在参与自我人口减少时，我感到最沮丧。在这一点上我们不能责怪联邦政府，我们不能责怪我们所在的州。我们必须在镜子里审视自己，并试图向自己解释这一点。
With the Chukchansi, a lot of the tribe's members thought disenrollment was OK as long as it was happening to other people. They never thought it would happen to them, so they didn't stand up against it. Even the current opponents of disenrollment, the four people elected to the tribal council who never got a chance to take their seat, they used to sit on the council years ago. And when they did, they presided over hundreds of disenrollments themselves.
对于查克钱西人，许多部落成员认为只要这种事发生在别人身上就没问题。他们从没想过会发生在自己身上，所以他们没有站出来反对。即使是目前反对取消资格的人，那四位当选但从未有机会就职的部落委员会成员，他们多年前也曾在委员会任职。那时，他们自己也主持了数百次取消资格。
At this point, no one feels safe. Even Reggie Lewis, the tribal chairman who refused to give up his seat in the election. Even he can imagine a future council trying to kick him out.
在这一点上，没人感到安全。即使是雷吉·刘易斯，那位在选举中拒绝放弃席位的部落主席。即使是他也能想象未来的委员会试图把他踢出去。
The reason will be whatever they want to say, because they will be the ultimate say so. It doesn't matter what is right or what is wrong. I have the documentation to show that I am from this area. I have established a special relationship with people that are in the Wyatt and Ramirez family.
原因将是他们想说的任何事情，因为他们将拥有最终决定权。对错并不重要。我有文件证明我来自这个地区。我已经与怀亚特和拉米雷斯家庭的人建立了特殊关系。
He's talking about the two families in the tribe that folks say are staunch supporters of disenrollment-- the Wyatts and the Ramirezes.
他在谈论部落中人们所说的坚决支持取消资格的两个家庭——怀亚特和拉米雷斯家族。
I cut timber for 40 years and I got Mike Ramirez jobs. I worked with Mike. His father used to come up and get drunk with my father. I went over and had beers with his father and my father.
我伐木40年，我给迈克·拉米雷斯找了工作。我和迈克一起工作。他父亲过去常和我父亲一起喝醉。我过去常和我父亲还有他父亲一起喝酒。
His sister was married to one of my cousins. And they lived right next door to me on my allotment on top of the hill here in Coarsegold. And so I know that I have established close ties with these guys over the years. And if they want to say that I'm not a member and they want to kick me out, that's on them.
他的姐姐嫁给了我的一个表亲。他们就住在我科斯戈尔德山上分配的土地隔壁。所以我知道这些年来我和这些人建立了密切的联系。如果他们想说我不是成员并想把我踢出去，那是他们的事。
Meanwhile at the casino, things aren't looking too good. Another tribe is planning to build a competing casino just 30 miles down the road. And Reggie Lewis told me the Chukchansi casino is still $250 million in debt from its construction.
与此同时，在赌场，情况看起来不太好。另一个部落计划在30英里外建造一个竞争性赌场。雷吉·刘易斯告诉我，查克钱西赌场在建设中仍欠债2.5亿美元。
About a year and a half ago, it missed a payment on that debt. He says they might miss another this month. He told me that if they do miss that payment, members of the tribe might not get their payouts or benefits.
大约一年半前，他们错过了一笔债务还款。他说他们这个月可能还会错过。他告诉我，如果他们真的错过了那笔还款，部落成员可能就拿不到分红或福利了。
The tribe has gone through all this heartache. It's on track to disenroll the majority of its members. If the point was to generate a higher payout for everyone who remained, that might not be panning out.
部落经历了所有这些心碎的事情。它正走在取消大部分成员资格的轨道上。如果目的是为所有留下的人产生更高的回报，这可能并没有奏效。
David Ferry in Oakland. Coming up-- whispering, it's not just for libraries anymore. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
奥克兰的大卫·费里。接下来——耳语，不仅仅适用于图书馆了。一分钟后回来。来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. Bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Tribes. Stories of people who believe they are part of these big groups that may or may not necessarily want them. We've arrived at Act 2 of our program.
《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题。为你带来关于该主题的不同类型的故事。今天的节目，部落。人们相信自己是这些大型群体的一部分，而这些群体未必一定想要他们。我们来到了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, A Tribe Called Rest.
第二幕，一个叫“休息”的部落。
You know, sometimes it can be easy to believe that you are in a tribe of one-- alone there by yourself. Andrea Seigel tells this story about finding out that she is undeniably not alone.
你知道，有时很容易相信你是一个人的部落——独自在那里。安德里亚·西格尔讲述了这个关于发现自己绝非孤身一人的故事。
In the fourth grade, I had this one friend Mindy. She was OK to hang out with and all. But what was really great about her was that she would always want to see whatever stuff I had in my room. If I sat her down in front of my shell collection, she would delicately go through it one shell at a time. She'd murmur to herself what she liked about each shell, and I'd get this tingling throughout my skull.
在四年级时，我有一个朋友明迪。和她在一起相处还好。但她真正棒的地方在于，她总是想看我房间里的任何东西。如果我让她坐在我的贝壳收藏前，她会小心翼翼地一个一个查看。她会对着自己低声念叨她喜欢每个贝壳的什么，我的头骨里就会有一种刺痛感。
I know how weird that sounds. But it was like starbursts in my head. Starbursts that open on the crown and then sparkle down at the nape like this warm, glittering water rushing under your scalp.
我知道这听起来有多奇怪。但这就像我脑子里的星爆。星爆在头顶绽放，然后像温暖、闪烁的水流在头皮下奔涌一样，一直闪烁到颈背。
I'd seek this feeling out, starting when I was seven. I'd go to the library so I could sit in a big, quiet room, and listen to pages being turned. There was a boring librarian who everyone in fifth grade hated. But I loved her, because when she would read us stories in her soft voice, she'd turn my head into a snow globe.
我从7岁起就开始寻找这种感觉。我会去图书馆，这样就可以坐在一个安静的大房间里，听翻书的声音。有一个五年级所有人都讨厌的无聊女图书员。但我爱她，因为当她用柔和的声音给我们读书时，她会把我的头变成一个雪花球。
I was an anxious kid. I worried about getting homework finished, even back when homework didn't count for anything. But while I was getting this tingling in my head, my anxiety just magically fell away. And afterward, I'd actually feel kind of good for a half hour.
我是一个焦虑的孩子。我担心作业写不完，即使在作业毫无意义的时候也是如此。但当我头里有这种刺痛感时，我的焦虑就会神奇地消失。之后，我会感觉半小时内心情都很好。
Then I found this public access lady on TV who used to show you how to stencil flowers on a wall. She gave me the tingling. I'd also get it watching the late, great Bob Ross teach how to paint mountains on PBS.
然后我在电视上发现了这位公共频道女士，她过去常教你怎么在墙上镂花。她给了我那种刺痛感。看着伟大的鲍勃·罗斯在公共电视台上教人怎么画山，我也会有这种感觉。
So we have black, blue, crimson, little bit of brown. Now then, barely touch the canvas.
所以我们有黑色、蓝色、深红色，一点棕色。好了，轻轻接触画布。
So there's Bob Ross. And I'm eight and sitting on the carpet in the den, watching him delicately mix paint colors in close up. And I am going into a trance. My jaw kind of goes slack. My eyes are probably a little glassy. And my head is a globe.
那是鲍勃·罗斯。我是个8岁的孩子，坐在书房的地毯上，看着他近距离地小心翼翼地混合油漆颜色。我进入了一种恍惚状态。我的下巴有点松弛。我的眼睛可能有点发直。我的头是个球体。
Take a little blue and white here-- just mix it together. And once again, flap our little tiny roll of paint.
蘸一点蓝色和白色——就这样混合在一起。再一次，拍打我们那小小的油漆卷。
So as I grew up, I never told my parents about this. Never talked to anybody. I assumed the tingling was an almost pervy way I was miswired. I felt ashamed about it, and all I understood was that I didn't want anyone to know.
随着成长，我从未告诉过父母这件事。从没跟任何人说过。我以为那种刺痛是我大脑连接错误的某种有点变态的方式。我对此感到羞愧，我唯一明白的是我不希望任何人知道。
It became even more extreme as an adult. As a kid I was only allowed to watch a certain amount of television. But once I was old enough to own my own TV, I would stay up until 4:00 AM watching home shopping network night after night. Soft-spoken women talked about the jewelry in very detailed, intricate, precious ways, and I loved it. People were confused about why I watched so much home shopping, because I never bought anything.
成年后，这变得更加极端。小时候，我只被允许看一定数量的电视。但一旦我足够大，拥有了自己的电视，我就会整夜整夜地熬到凌晨4点看家庭购物频道。轻声细语的女士们以非常详尽、复杂、珍贵的方式谈论珠宝，我喜欢它。人们对为什么我看那么多家庭购物感到困惑，因为我什么都没买。
But the starbursts worked as well as an adult as they had as a kid. They calm my anxiety. And calming is important, because I'm still an anxious person. In fact, I'm way worse as an adult-- there's a lot more to be anxious about.
但星爆带来的效果和我小时候一样好。它们平息了我的焦虑。平息很重要，因为我仍然是一个焦虑的人。事实上，成年后我更严重了——有更多的事情要焦虑。
And I still never told anyone about what was going on inside my head, not even my boyfriend Brent. We've been together for years. We have a kid together. We tell each other everything. I've told him some really horrible, embarrassing things about myself, but I didn't tell him this. Like, I would never turn to him during dinner and ask, so when the fork just delicately pinged against the knife, did you get tingles throughout your brain, too?
我仍然没告诉过任何人我脑子里在发生什么，甚至没有告诉我的男朋友布伦特。我们在一起好几年了。我们有一个孩子。我们什么都告诉对方。我告诉过他一些关于我自己的非常可怕、尴尬的事情，但我没告诉过他这个。比如，我永远不会在晚餐时转向他问：嘿，当叉子轻轻敲击盘子时，你的大脑里也会有刺痛感吗？
A few years ago, I started seeking out this stuff on YouTube. I began with makeup tutorials, because I love to hear the tapping of a brush on a Mac pigment bottle, or the clicking up of an eyeliner pencil. That's how I moved on to this woman named Senada, who does something called haul videos, that's H-A-U-L, which are just her talking about what she bought on a shopping trip. These kind of videos are actually really popular-- there are tons of them.
几年前，我开始在YouTube上寻找这类内容。我从化妆教程开始，因为我喜欢听刷子敲击Mac颜料瓶的声音，或者眼线笔盖扣上的声音。这就是我如何转而观看这位名叫塞纳达的女士的内容，她做一些叫“Haul（战利品）”的视频，就是她谈论购物之旅买到了什么。这类视频实际上非常受欢迎——有很多。
Hi, everyone. Welcome back to my channel. Today I wanted to show you what I got from the Versace for H&M. So as you can see I have--
嗨，大家好。欢迎回到我的频道。今天我想展示一下我从Versace for H&M买到的东西。正如你们所见，我有——
So I was up to watching two or three hours a day. And I know this is all starting to sound like porn and someone's obsession with porn. But it's not porn, even if it does operate a little bit like porn. All the searching for videos, trying to find exactly the right moment or performer, developing very specific tastes and preferences.
所以我每天看两三个小时。我知道这听起来像是色情作品和某人对色情作品的痴迷。但它不是色情，即使它确实有点像色情。所有寻找视频、试图找到恰好的时刻或表演者、发展出非常特定的品味和偏好。
I wanted someone speaking in lightly accented English. And I wanted them talking to me about jewelry, slowly and deliberately. And preferably, it's tacky or cheap jewelry that isn't being treated as if it's tacky and cheap. And just like porn, the effect wears off after a while. You have to find new videos.
我想要有人用轻微的口音说英语。我想让他们慢慢地、深思熟虑地跟我谈论珠宝。最好是看起来很俗气或廉价，但被当成不俗气、不廉价的那种珠宝。就像色情一样，效果过了一会儿会消失。你必须找到新的视频。
Finally one night over the recent holidays, I was suddenly out of videos. I'd exhausted all my usual haul favorites. Despairing, I typed jewelry collection into the search box. Nothing I hadn't seen already.
终于，最近假期的一个晚上，我的视频看完了。我的常规“战利品”视频全都看完了。绝望中，我在搜索框里输入了“珠宝收藏”。没有我没看过的。
That was when I had an idea. I'd noticed a number of the haulers on YouTube who had accented English had trouble with the spelling of jewelry. I typed in jewelry again, this time with two Ls.
就在那时我有了个主意。我注意到YouTube上许多有口音的视频制作者在“珠宝（jewelry）”的拼写上有困难。我再次输入了珠宝，这次用了两个L。
YouTube returned a video at the top of the search entitled ASMR, Old Jewelry Collection, Show and Tell Whisperer. It was made by YouTuber called--
YouTube返回了搜索结果顶部的一个视频，标题是“ASMR，旧珠宝收藏，展示与讲述耳语者”。它是由一个名叫——的YouTuber制作的。
TheWaterwhispers Ilse.
TheWaterwhispers Ilse（低语者伊尔塞）。
That was TheWaterwhispers Ilse. On the screen, a woman smiled and waved and then she began.
那是TheWaterwhispers Ilse。屏幕上，一个女人微笑着挥手，然后她开始了。
Hey guys, today I'm at my grandpa's house and I'm going to share something personal with you guys. It's kind of a show and tell video, because I'm going to show you the jewelry-- I always struggle with that word.
嘿大家，今天我在我爷爷家，我要和你们分享一些私人的东西。这有点像展示与讲述视频，因为我要展示珠宝——我总是对那个词感到挣扎。
I was like, what the hell is this? I kept watching.
我就想，这到底是什么鬼？我继续看。
I'm going to show you the jewelry of my grandma. She passed away in 2008. And she was actually, together with Bob Ross, one of the first people who gave me ASMR when I was a kid.
我要展示我奶奶的珠宝。她于2008年去世。事实上，她和鲍勃·罗斯一起，是我小时候第一次给我ASMR体验的人之一。
I was stunned. I mean, I was loving this video. But also, one, I was shocked by the Bob Ross mention. And two, I was worried that something was wrong with this Ilsa, because I thought ASMR sounded like a medical condition. I instantly assumed that "M" stood for mute, and that Ilsa was some kind of partial mute who could only whisper.
我惊呆了。我是说，我很喜欢这个视频。但同时，第一，我对提到鲍勃·罗斯感到震惊。第二，我担心这个伊尔塞有什么问题，因为我以为ASMR听起来像是一种医疗状况。我立即假设“M”代表静音（mute），而伊尔塞是某种只能耳语的部分哑巴。
So I googled ASMR, which led me knowyourmeme.com. And an entry for ASMR that reads, "Autonomous Sensory Meridian Response is a term used to describe a sensory experience characterized by a tingling sensation in the head and scalp which can be triggered by sounds like whispering or brushing, and visual stimulus like painting or drawing." It continued. "On YouTube, the phenomenon inspired the creation of whisperer videos, in which people attempt to trigger the viewer's ASMR by speaking in a soft voice and making various sounds with inanimate objects."
所以我谷歌了ASMR，这让我知道了knowyourmeme.com。关于ASMR的一个条目写道：“自发性知觉经络反应是一个术语，用于描述一种感官体验，其特征是头部和头皮的刺痛感，可以由耳语或刷洗等声音，以及绘画或素描等视觉刺激引发。”它继续写道：“在YouTube上，这种现象激发了耳语视频的创作，视频中人们试图通过轻声说话和用无生命物体制造各种声音来引发观看者的ASMR。”
At this point I started saying, oh my God! Oh my God! And Brent on the other couch grew worried and asked what? What?
此时我开始尖叫，天啊！天啊！而在另一张沙发上的布伦特变得担心并问什么？什么？
I clicked on a second link, which took me to an article titled ASMR, the good feeling no one can explain. The author writes, from what I understand from conversations with ASMRs, it's a tingle in your brain. A kind of pleasurable headache that can creep down your spine.
我点击了第二个链接，带我到了题为“ASMR，没人能解释的良好感觉”的文章。作者写道，据我从与ASMR爱好者的谈话中了解，这是大脑中的一种刺痛。一种可以爬下脊柱的令人愉悦的头痛。
I became about as excited as I've ever been, even flapping my hands. I clicked on TheWaterwhispers Ilse's website. At the top it said, for me, ASMR is not just a feeling, it's a lifestyle. And that sounds so incredibly lame, but what's hilarious is that it actually is a lifestyle-- it totally is. It's my lifestyle.
我变得前所未有的兴奋，甚至拍打着手。我点击了TheWaterwhispers Ilse的网站。在顶部写着：对我来说，ASMR不仅仅是一种感觉，它是一种生活方式。这听起来太没劲了，但有趣的是，它确实是一种生活方式——完全是。这是我的生活方式。
I had no idea that I was into ASMR, but for the past decade I've been dedicating an hour of my day to this. And I wasn't alone. That was incredible, learning that I wasn't alone. In an instant, I went from believing I was miswired to suddenly feeling like I was part of a special group of people with amazing sensitivities.
我不知道我竟然迷上了ASMR，但过去十年我每天花一小时在上面。我并不孤单。那太不可思议了，学习到我并不孤单。在那一瞬间，我从相信自己连接错误突然感到我是一个拥有惊人敏感性的特殊群体的一部分。
Not that science has confirmed that anything special's really going on. I haven't been able to find any published studies. There is a professor at Dartmouth who's overseeing a couple students. And they're going to put people with ASMR into an MRI tube and watch what happens in their brains while they're having head tingles. They hope to have results in the next month.
并不是说科学已经证实了有什么特别的事情正在发生。我没能找到任何已发表的研究。达特茅斯大学有一位教授正在监督几个学生。他们会把有ASMR的人放进核磁共振仪里，观看他们在头部刺痛时大脑中发生了什么。他们希望在下个月有结果。
That night I discovered ASMR, with my official-sounding acronym in hand, I came out and explained my head tingles to Brent. His eyes went wide. And when I played him the first few seconds of Ilse's jewelry video, he started laughing and said, you're loving that? Brent finds the whole thing hilarious. He had always just thought I was strange for watching hours of such boring stuff, but here I had an actual thing.
那天晚上我发现了ASMR，手里拿着我那听起来很官方的缩写，我出来向布伦特解释了我的头部刺痛。他的眼睛睁大了。当我给他放了伊尔塞珠宝视频的前几秒时，他开始大笑并说，你喜欢那个？布伦特觉得整件事非常搞笑。他一直以为我看这种无聊的东西几个小时很奇怪，但在这里我有一种实际的东西。
But the best part of knowing it's called ASMR, I found tons more videos. There are ASMR stars like Maria, a.k.a. GentleWhispering, with 77,000 subscribers, who does the most compelling napkin folding video I've ever seen. Then there's up and comers like Equine Cutie with close to 7,000 subscribers. She rehabilitates horses and her whisper voice sounds like she's always got a hard candy in her mouth-- except she doesn't.
但知道它叫ASMR最好的部分是，我找到了更多视频。有像Maria（又名GentleWhispering）这样的ASMR明星，有77000名订阅者，她做了我见过的最引人入胜的餐巾折叠视频。然后还有像Equine Cutie这样拥有近7000名订阅者的新星。她给马进行康复治疗，她的耳语声音听起来就像她嘴里一直含着硬糖——除了她并没有。
The clicky noises that you hear, honestly, that's just what happens when I whisper. Sorry if you don't really like it. I can't really do anything about it.
你听到的咔哒声，老实说，这就是我耳语时发生的情况。如果你真的不喜欢，很抱歉。我真的无能为力。
Viewers make online requests to their favorite video-making whisperers to do the things that trigger their head tingles. Everyone's needs are different. It's like an interactive choose your own adventure. But the whole story is about marbles clinking.
观众向他们最喜欢的视频制作人发出在线请求，去做触发他们头部刺痛的事情。每个人的需求都不同。这就像一个互动的选择你的冒险游戏。但整个故事是关于弹珠碰撞的。
TheWaterwhispers Ilse keeps a running public list of her fan's requests. Some of the pending ones include water bottle not filled completely with beads in it and move it around. Pick something up with tweezers and tell facts about it.
TheWaterwhispers Ilse保留了一份公开的粉丝请求列表。一些待处理的请求包括：装满珠子的水瓶没有完全填满并晃动它。用镊子捡起东西并讲述关于它的事实。
Could you do an unboxing video of a box of bon bons, and cut the bon bons in half to see what flavor they are? Role play-- sending a viewer on a mission as a spy. Role play-- be a doctor and diagnose a cold.
你能做一个糖果盒的开箱视频，并把糖果切成两半看看是什么味道吗？角色扮演——送一个观众去执行间谍任务。角色扮演——做一个医生并诊断感冒。
Almost every ASMR YouTuber makes role play videos in which they conduct fake customer service or spa or dermatology sessions. These videos are about someone being almost comically gentle with you.
几乎每个ASMR YouTuber都会做角色扮演视频，他们在视频中进行虚假的客户服务或水疗或皮肤科疗程。这些视频是关于某人对你极度温柔。
Hi there. Welcome to our spa. My name is Mol and I'm going to be taking care of you today, OK?
你好。欢迎来到我们的水疗中心。我的名字是莫尔，今天我来照顾你，好吗？
I know, I know-- these videos sound sexy. They are arguably sexy. Whispering sounds like pillow talk. The role plays feel pretty intimate.
我知道，我知道——这些视频听起来很性感。它们可以说很性感。耳语听起来像枕边细语。角色扮演感觉相当亲密。
And often the whisperers will just film their torso, because they're showing you the toiletry basket they prepared for guests or doing origami. And framing hands and arms also means a lot of closeups of chests. You see the problem. Under the videos, which are overwhelmingly done by women, the comments that go on for days are a mixed bag of blissed out ASMR supporters, and guys who see this as softcore softcore porn.
而且耳语者通常只会拍摄她们的躯干，因为她们在向你展示她们为客人准备的洗漱篮或做折纸。构图中的手和手臂也意味着大量的胸部特写。你看到问题了。在这些绝大多数由女性制作的视频下，那些延续数日的评论是幸福的ASMR支持者和把这视为软色情的男人之间的大杂烩。
The smutty responses are very frustrating to the whisperers. And take my word for it, there's nothing sexual about the feeling itself because it's actually the opposite of arousal. The starbursts produce a thorough calm that is almost stoner-like.
猥亵的回复对耳语者来说非常令人沮丧。相信我的话，这种感觉本身没有任何色情成分，因为它实际上与性唤起相反。星爆产生了一种近乎迷幻的彻底平静。
It seems worth mentioning, given where I'm speaking to you from right now, that public radio is also a trigger for lots of people. Recently, someone posted to a discussion group on Reddit, quote, "I almost crashed my car when I accidentally fell into an ASMR trance dream in an interview on All Things Considered the other day. I had to change the channel. Radiolab will often trigger for me, too. I actually get tingles from the opening theme."
鉴于我现在说话的地方，值得一提的是，公共广播对很多人来说也是一种触发因素。最近，有人在一个Reddit讨论组发布：“那天我差点撞车，因为我在听《凡事皆有考虑》的一篇采访时意外陷入了ASMR恍惚梦。我不得不换频道。《Radiolab》也经常触发我。我甚至从开头的主题曲中就能感到刺痛。”
Someone replied, quote, "Oh, man, I get overly excited when Garrison Keillor comes in. Prairie Home Companion is one of my favorite ASMR experiences."
有人回复：“天啊，当加里森·基勒进来时我太兴奋了。《草原家庭伴侣》是我最喜欢的ASMR体验之一。”
All this whisperer obsession has led to a lot of discussion in my home about whether I have a problem.
所有这种对耳语者的痴迷导致我家里关于我是否有问题的很多讨论。
Do you overall feel that I'm watching too many videos?
你总体上觉得我看的视频太多了吗？
Yeah. I mean, I think you should mix it up with another hobby that you enjoy. There have been days where I caught you watching hours of whispering about people doing role plays of their childhood and stuff. And I think, I don't think I want to be in a position where I felt like I needed to watch these for hours.
是啊。我是说，我觉得你应该穿插一些你喜欢的其他爱好。有些日子我抓到你看了几个小时关于人们做童年角色扮演之类的耳语。我想，我不想处于那种我觉得自己需要看这些几个小时的情况。
Yeah, but you spend a ton of time on internet. Just more time surfing the internet than I do watching videos. So does that concern you about yourself?
是啊，但你花在互联网上的时间也很多。比起我看视频，你上网的时间更多。这会让你对自己感到担忧吗？
Yes, it does. I don't know why we're making this about me all of a sudden.
是的，确实。我不知道为什么我们突然要把话题转到我身上。
He thinks his rigorous internet reading is more worthwhile than my ASMR, because he's gathering information that makes him a more interesting person to talk to, like at a party. But he says my watching is just zombie-ish.
他认为他严格的互联网阅读比我的ASMR更有价值，因为他在收集信息，使他成为在派对上谈话更有趣的人。但他说是我的观看方式像僵尸一样。
So it does annoy me that hours and hours a day watching these videos. It seems like we could take some of that time and use it doing my stuff, you know?
所以，每天花几个小时看这些视频确实让我感到烦躁。看起来我们可以拿走其中一些时间去做我的事情，你懂的？
But in my defense, we do do his stuff. The other night I agreed to watch The Twilight Saga: Breaking Dawn, Part 2, Brent's choice. And I used it as an opportunity to try to educate Brent about the power of ASMR. I pointed out to him when Bella becomes a vampire she suddenly notices every minuscule thing around her, every tiny sound. I said that's the state-- superhuman laser, better than a normal person.
但作为辩护，我们确实做了他的事情。那天晚上我同意看《暮光之城：破晓（下）》，这是布伦特的选择。我把它当作一个机会来尝试教育布伦特关于ASMR的力量。我向他指出，当贝拉成为吸血鬼时，她突然注意到周围的每一个微小事物，每一个微小的声音。我说这就是那种状态——超人的激光，比正常人更好。
I'm never going to get enough of this. We don't get tired. We don't have to rest or catch our breath or eat.
我永远也不会对这个感到满足。我们不会累。我们不需要休息或喘气或吃饭。
Brent doesn't buy this. He doesn't understand.
布伦特不买账。他不理解。
Andrea Seigel, she's a novelist with several books, including Like the Red Panda.
安德里亚·西格尔，她是一位小说家，有几本书，包括《像红熊猫一样》。
Act Three, I Am Curious Yellow.
第三幕，我很好奇黄色。
I originally heard a version of this next story on the public radio show Snap Judgment. It's about a guy who wants in on a group he definitely was not born into and, at the outset anyway, seems very unlikely to be accepted by. This story is told by this filmmaker named Debbie Lum. Here she is.
我最初在公共广播节目《快照判断》上听到了这个下一个故事的版本。这是一个关于一个家伙想要进入一个他绝对不是出身的群体的故事，起初看起来很不可能被接受。这个故事是由一位名叫黛比·卢姆的电影制片人讲述的。她在这儿。
You know, it's hard to grow up in America as an Asian woman and not encounter some Caucasian, usually Caucasian man, who has this sort of unusual attraction for Asian women. There's terms for it, like "rice king," or "yellow fever." In my life I've been hit on by so many men who would sort of stare a little bit too long. Then they kind of come up and try to speak to you in the Asian language that you don't speak.
你知道，在美国作为一个亚洲女性很难不遇到一些高加索人，通常是高加索男性，他们对亚洲女性有一种不同寻常的吸引力。有这样的术语，比如“米饭王”或“黄热病”。在我的生活中，我被许多男人骚扰过，他们会盯着看的时间有点过长。然后他们会过来尝试用你不会说的亚洲语言和你说话。
I was really tired of being objectified. And I thought hey, wouldn't it be a great idea to just turn the tables and point the camera in their direction? I decided to make the documentary Seeking Asian Female.
我真的厌倦了被客体化。我想嘿，把桌子转过来，把摄像机对准他们的方向，这不是一个好主意吗？我决定拍摄纪录片《寻求亚洲女性》。
So I went onto Craigslist, and websites like AsianFriendFinder.com, which they specialize in introducing Western men to Asian women. And I started asking the men who post ads there if they would talk to me for my film. I just wanted to understand why.
所以我上了Craigslist和像AsianFriendFinder.com这样的网站，它们专门介绍西方男性给亚洲女性认识。我开始询问在那里发广告的男人，是否愿意为了我的电影和我交谈。我只是想了解为什么。
It's their hair. It's the long, black hair that's really eye-catching.
是她们的头发。那是真正引人注目的长黑发。
It's the whole mysterious kind of look.
是那种神秘的整体外表。
I think they give more consideration to how the man feels than sometimes themselves.
我认为她们比她们自己有时更关注男人的感受。
Yeah, they are kind of subtle and kind of quiet.
是的，她们有点微妙，有点安静。
But Steven, in particular, had this kind of unfiltered quality about him. And he'd say things like, 'You know, I was probably originally looking for a slave when I first started." And I'm quoting him. And he would kind of laugh about that.
但史蒂文，特别有那种未经过滤的品质。他会说一些诸如“你知道，我刚开始时可能最初在找一个奴隶”之类的话。我是引用他的话。他会对此有点大笑。
The idyllic servant girl who cooks these beautiful meals. And you think gee, would it be like that?
烹制这些美味佳肴的田园牧歌式的女仆。你会想天哪，会是那样吗？
Of course, as an individual, I felt a little bit disturbed. But as a filmmaker, he was quite fascinating. So then I started filming him.
当然，作为一个个体，我感到有点不安。但作为电影制片人，他相当迷人。所以我开始拍摄他。
She looks so Chinese.
她看起来很中国。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
You can't look any more Chinese.
你看上去不能再更中国了。
What does that mean, she looks so Chinese?
那是什么意思，她看起来很中国？
You look really Chinese, too.
你看上去也很中国。
He really wasn't marriage material for any woman. He didn't have a lot of money. He didn't own a house. He didn't even own a car. Yet he had such an extreme undying commitment to finding Asian women, I thought he was just sort of living in a fantasy.
他真的不是任何女性的结婚对象。他没有很多钱。他不拥有房子。他甚至没有车。然而，他对于寻找亚洲女性有一种极端的、不灭的承诺，我以为他只是生活在幻想中。
He showed me all of these files that he kept-- mail order catalogs. There were just pictures of hundreds of young Asian women.
他给我看了他保存的所有这些文件——邮购目录。全是数百名年轻亚洲女性的照片。
These are different girls that I've written to. They're all just so beautiful.
这些是我写过信的不同女孩。她们全都太美了。
I almost felt sorry for Steven. Any woman that he became an online pen pal with, he basically asked them to marry him. And these women that he was dating online, they knew that he was this prey that they could take advantage of. He would just send them money. I could see that actually the yellow fever was hurting Steven more than it was hurting the women that he was pursuing.
我几乎为史蒂文感到难过。任何和他成为在线笔友的女性，他基本上都求婚了。而这些他在网上约会的女性，她们知道他是可以被利用的猎物。他只是给她们寄钱。我能看出实际上“黄热病”对史蒂文造成的伤害比对他追求的女性造成的伤害更大。
I've been watching him search for many years and I thought that he was never going to find anyone. And then I got this call from him, and he said would you like to film my wedding? I found somebody in China who's going to marry me.
我看着他寻找很多年了，我以为他永远也找不到任何人。然后我接到了他的电话，他说你愿意拍摄我的婚礼吗？我在中国找到了一个要嫁给我的人。
I couldn't believe it. When he told me he was getting married to Sandy, I was really afraid she would fit that stereotype of being a gold digger, a dragon lady. I had this really bad feeling that this was just going to get really ugly.
我简直不敢相信。当他告诉我他要和桑迪结婚时，我真的很担心她会符合那种淘金者、龙女的刻板印象。我有这种非常糟糕的感觉，觉得这只会变得非常丑陋。
So the first time I met Sandy was when she walked off the plane at San Francisco International Airport and landed in America for the first time.
所以我第一次见到桑迪是在她走出旧金山国际机场的飞机，第一次登陆美国时。
This is Sandy.
这是桑迪。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
She seemed really sweet. She seemed really innocent. I was thinking, how is this possible? She's 30, he's 60.
她看起来真的很甜。她看起来真的很天真。我当时在想，这怎么可能？她30岁，他60岁。
And then I find out, she barely knew any English and Steven didn't speak any Chinese. All of a sudden I'm thinking, oh my gosh, this poor young woman. She has no idea what's happening. And I felt this overwhelming need to protect her.
然后我发现，她几乎不懂什么英语，史蒂文也不会说中文。突然间我在想，哦天哪，这个可怜的年轻女子。她根本不知道发生了什么。我感到有一种无法抑制的保护她的需要。
The first thing that Sandy did was that she took over the kitchen. And she just started scrubbing and cleaning. He loved it, obviously. He was in heaven. She would cook these elaborate Chinese meals for him. She told Steven, I knew you weren't rich, but I didn't know you were poor.
桑迪做的第一件事是接管厨房。她开始擦洗和清洁。他显然爱死了。他在天堂里。她会为他烹制这些精致的中国菜。她告诉史蒂文，我知道你不富有，但我不知道你这么穷。
People say your husband have a house? Have a car? No, no house and no car, no money.
人们说你丈夫有房子吗？有车吗？没有，没有房子也没有车，没钱。
Sandy came from Huangshan in Anhui province. Anhui province is one of the poorest regions in China, and she grew up as a tea farmer. Then she migrated to Shenzhen, China. She found her way out of the factory floor and eventually became the executive secretary at a fashion company.
桑迪来自安徽省黄山。安徽省是中国最贫穷的地区之一，她成长为一名茶农。然后她迁移到中国深圳。她找到了走出工厂地板的方法，最终成为了一家时尚公司的行政秘书。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
Everybody says it doesn't make sense. You should try to find a younger guy. And why would you choose him? I felt like we had so many similar interests and hobbies. And he's just so special, he's really not like anyone else.
每个人都说这说不通。你应该尝试找一个年轻一点的男人。你为什么会选择他？我感觉我们有那么多相似的兴趣和爱好。而且他真的很特别，他真的不像任何人。
In China, it's not like I could ever marry someone rich. I've never wanted to marry for money. I think you marry the same kind of person that you are. It's better to be realistic, right?
在中国，不像我能嫁给富人。我从来没想过为钱结婚。我认为你和你是同一种人结婚。最好现实点，对吧？
They would pull out their iPhones and use Google Translator and type in sentences to each other. He would be telling jokes, and she would be laughing at them. There was this chemistry that I hadn't really even factored into the equation.
他们会拿出iPhone使用谷歌翻译，并互相打字句子。他会讲笑话，她会笑。有一种我甚至没真正计入等式的化学反应。
Sometimes I'll come home and she'll be hiding behind the refrigerator. Or one time she was hiding in the closet and she lets me look around. She'll be in there smiling, and it's funny. It's funny. The day is full of little things like that. That's easy to share.
有时我回家，她会躲在冰箱后面。或者有一次她躲在壁橱里，让我环顾四周。她会躲在那里面微笑着，这很有趣。这很有趣。日子里充满了那些小事。很容易分享。
And then I got a call. And it was Steven saying you have to help me, we've had a major misunderstanding. And so I show up at their apartment. Sandy had found all these pictures that Steven had collected of all the Asian women from before. And she was really upset about the presents he had sent to his ex-girlfriends in China and she just went ballistic.
然后我接到了一个电话。那是史蒂文说你必须帮我，我们发生了一个重大的误解。于是我出现在他们的公寓里。桑迪发现了史蒂文收藏的所有以前那些亚洲女性的照片。她对史蒂文寄给他在中国的前女友们的礼物非常不安，她简直暴走了。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
In China, if you break up with someone you can't still be friends. She asked him to buy all these things for her. Chinese people can't casually accept precious gifts from other people. It's stupid.
在中国，如果你和某人分手，你们不能再做朋友。她让他为她买这些东西。中国人不能随意接受别人珍贵的礼物。太蠢了。
Oh my gosh, these are genuine feelings that she has for him. Sandy was really hurt. So I'm hearing them fight, and they're not communicating. It was really hard to watch them struggle, so I began translating.
哦天哪，这些是她对他拥有的真实感情。桑迪真的受了伤。所以我听着他们争吵，他们没有沟通。看着他们挣扎真的很痛苦，所以我开始翻译。
[SPEAKING CHINESE].
（说中文）。
OK, Steven, why is it that you still have pictures of Molly?
好的，史蒂文，为什么你还有莫莉的照片？
It took a while to fade away, but I'm way over it.
花了一段时间才消失，但我已经完全放下了。
Let me translate. [SPEAKING CHINESE].
让我翻译。（说中文）。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
She said that's what you say, but how do I know that your heart feels that way for real?
她说那是你说的，但我怎么知道你的内心真的有那种感觉？
I can only prove my love day by day.
我只能日复一日地证明我的爱。
Oh my gosh, I can't translate that.
哦天哪，我翻译不了那个。
At the end of the scene, I realized wait a minute, they've kind of made up. And how much of that was because I was translating? This is not what you're supposed to do as a documentary filmmaker. It was supposed to be about them. But I was becoming a character in the story.
在那场戏的最后，我意识到等一下，他们算是和解了。其中有多少是因为我在翻译？这不是作为纪录片制片人你应该做的。它应该是关于他们的。但我正在成为故事中的一个角色。
When Sandy arrived in America, she came in on the K-1 Fiance Visa. And the way that works is you have 90 days to decide whether or not the person that you're engaged to is the person that you really want to marry. And if you don't marry that person, you have to go home.
当桑迪到达美国时，她持有K-1未婚夫签证进入。它的运作方式是你必须有90天的时间决定你订婚的人是否是你真正想结婚的人。如果你不和那个人结婚，你就必须回家。
Eventually they asked me to translate more and more. As I was translating them, I really started not just translating, but realized that I was mediating and kind of becoming their marriage counselor.
最终他们要求我翻译得越来越多。在翻译他们时，我真的开始不仅仅是翻译，而是意识到我在调解，算是成为了他们的婚姻顾问。
Help me. When she gets mad, she doesn't communicate. So I just have to guess what she's mad about.
帮帮我。当她生气时，她不沟通。所以我只能猜测她在生什么气。
It got pretty crazy. I'd get these late night phone calls from them. Any time they had a conflict they would call me.
这变得相当疯狂。我会接到他们的深夜电话。每当他们有冲突时，他们就会打电话给我。
As they really got to know each other, the reality hit. Her real-life personality came out, and she was no longer this figment of his imagination, or this ideal woman. She demanded that he step up to the plate and clean the house as well.
当他们真正了解对方时，现实打击了。她的现实个性表现出来，她不再是他想象中的虚构人物，或者那种理想女性。她要求他也必须挺身而出，也要打扫房子。
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
What? Speak in English. We got to do that first before everything else?
什么？用英语说。我们在做其他事情之前必须先做那个吗？
No, only listen. Clean house first.
不，只听。先打扫房子。
This is how I'm supposed to deal with it? You dump it in here?
这就是我应该处理它的方式吗？你把它倒在这里？
I'm sorry.
对不起。
[CRASH]
（碰撞声）
That's how you dumped it. That's how you give it to me.
这就是你倒掉它的方式。这就是你把它给我的方式。
[CRYING]
（哭泣）
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
（说中文）
This is my life and the man I chose. It's too late to go home now, I'll lose face. If I go home, I won't-- it's impossible.
这就是我的生活和我选择的男人。现在回家太晚了，我会丢脸。如果我回家，我就不会——这不可能。
You see, in China everyone will talk behind my back. I won't be able to lift my head in public. So now I can only move forward, I can't look back.
你看，在中国每个人都会在背后议论我。我无法在公共场合抬头。所以现在我只能前进，我不能回头。
It's really clear what you're getting out of this relationship, I think. What do you think she gets out of it?
我想我很清楚你从这段关系中得到了什么。你认为她从中得到了什么？
A chance at a new life, a new world? Oh, god.
一个新生活、一个新世界的机会？天哪。
So right when Sandy was really having some doubts about getting married, Steven turned to me and he just came out and thanked me. And he said, if it hadn't been for you, Sandy would've gone back to China by now. She told him that.
所以就在桑迪真正对结婚有一些疑问时，史蒂文转向我，他直接出来感谢了我。他说，如果不是你，桑迪现在已经回中国了。她是那样告诉他的。
I absolutely questioned whether I had done the right thing at that moment. Would she not perhaps be better off if she'd stayed in China or just went home? Shenzhen is this thriving metropolis. And she'd be living in her own culture where she could have a home, have friends, and have her life.
在那一刻我绝对质疑我是否做了正确的事情。如果她留在中国或者只是回家，她会不会过得更好？深圳是一个繁荣的大都市。她将生活在自己的文化中，在那里她可以有家、有朋友，拥有自己的生活。
Marriage should not be entered into lightly, but with certainty, mutual respect, and a sense of reverence that does not preclude humor or--
婚姻不应轻率地进入，而应带着确定性、相互尊重，以及一种不排除幽默感的敬畏感——
Here they are, about to get married, and there's all these unanswered questions.
他们在这里，即将结婚，而所有这些悬而未决的问题。
With this ring, I thee wed and offer as a symbol of our true love.
带着这枚戒指，我娶你，并作为我们真爱的象征献给你。
I now pronounce you husband and wife.
现在我宣布你们为夫妻。
Did I do the right thing? Many times I wanted to just tell her it doesn't matter. Just to pick her up and take her back to China.
我做了正确的事吗？很多次我想告诉她那没关系。只是带她回去中国。
But that that's also making an assumption that I know the right thing for her. It's so easy to go to this place where Sandy was a victim, but that doesn't give her enough credit. She was somebody who knew how to take care of herself, and knew exactly what was the right thing for her.
但这也在做一个假设，即我知道对她来说什么是正确的事。很容易走到桑迪是受害者的这个地方，但这并没有给她足够的信任。她是一个知道如何照顾自己，并确切知道什么是对自己正确的事的人。
And after the wedding, I was relieved to see that Steven really progressed. I watched him clean up his act slowly. He worked really hard to try to win the heart of this young Chinese woman. He actually did the housework and cleaned the kitchen.
婚后，我很欣慰看到史蒂文真的进步了。我看着他慢慢改掉恶习。他努力工作试图赢得这位年轻中国女性的心。他实际上做了家务，打扫了厨房。
At first I went into this search thinking the traditional stereotype of getting someone to stay home, do the housework, clean, take care of me, that kind of thing. But that's not very growth oriented.
起初我进入这种搜索时想着那种找个人待在家里、做家务、打扫、照顾我之类事情的传统刻板印象。但那并不是以成长为导向的。
Oh! Oh my gosh! Everything looks good, clean. Oh! Thank you.
哦！哦天哪！一切看起来都很好，干净。哦！谢谢。
That's what I like.
那是我喜欢的。
Oh, gosh!
哦，天哪！
The crazy thing is, I'm not bothered by Steven's yellow fever in the same way I was before. You know, originally he was just this guy I wanted to expose. I never imagined that I would see a couple like Steven and Sandy, and actually be rooting for them to make it.
疯狂的事情是，我不再像以前那样被史蒂文的黄热病所困扰。你知道，起初他只是我想曝光的那个家伙。我从来没想过我会看到像史蒂文和桑迪这样的夫妇，并实际上在支持他们成功。
Debbie Lum, talking about her film Seeking Asian Female which is available online. Just Google it, a companion video series about dating and race. And Yellow Fever will launch in a week at theyrealsobeautiful.com. You can hear Snap Judgment, where that story came from, on many public radio stations. Or get their podcast for free at snapjudgment.org. Stephanie Foo produced this story for them.
黛比·卢姆，谈论她的电影《寻求亚洲女性》，它可以在线获得。谷歌一下，关于约会和种族的配套视频系列。而《黄热病》将在下周在theyrealsobeautiful.com发布。你可以在许多公共广播电台听到那个故事来源的《快照判断》。或者在snapjudgment.org免费获取他们的播客。斯蒂芬妮·富为他们制作了这个故事。
[MUSIC - "YOU GOT WHAT YOU WANTED" BY IKE & TINA TURNER]
（音乐 - 艾克与蒂娜·特纳的“你得到了你想要的”）
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek and myself with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike.
我们的节目今天由米基·米克和我与亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克制作。
Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Production help from Phia Bennin Seth Lind is our operations director, Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Music help today from Damien Graef from Rob Geddis.
我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。来自菲亚·本宁 Seth Lind 的制作帮助是我们的运营总监，艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。今天来自 Damien Graef 和 Rob Geddis 的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. He stopped by the office to show me his brand new dance moves.
我们的网站 ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。WBEZ 管理层监督我们的节目，由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责。他顺便来办公室向我展示了他全新的舞步。
I said hit it, and I went down and hit the floor. Well then, I couldn't get up because, of course, I've got a bad hip and bad knees.
我说趴下，于是我倒下趴在地板上。嗯，然后我起不来了，因为当然，我的髋关节和膝盖都不好。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。